وفي تصريحات اخرى لنائب رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني قال في مقابله مع قناه سي
ام بي سي ان دوله قطر لديها موقف سياسي
واضح للغايه يقوم على عدم قبول قيام دوله
بغزوه اخرى
او استخدامها المدنيين واظهر ذلك خلال
التصويت في الامم المتحده
الاقتصادي قال وزير الخارجيه القطري من
العالم يقف موحدا لتصدي لبعض القضايا دون
غيرها واضاف انهم من المهم ان يقف المجتمع
الدولي مع قضايا الشرق الاوسط بنفس
الطريقه
كلاش كلاش
جميع ملتزما بميثاق الامم المتحده لكن ما
يصدمون في المنطقه هو اننا نرى المجتمع
الدوليه يتحرك فقط لبعض القضايا دون غيرها
لقد علينا في الشرق الاوسط لعقود من كل
انواع الانتهاكات لمواثيق الامم المتحده
في قضيه النزاع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي او
في قضيه سوريا وقضايا كثيره اخرى ونريد ان
نرى المجتمع الدولي يقف لهذه القضايا التي
ما زالت معاناتها مستمره بنفس الطريقه